[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما اكلنا ومش ربنا وملبسنا
وحتى ما سكنا قائم على الفصول والمواسم
والاكل عندنا ينقسم الى قسمين شتوي وصيفي
الصيفي قائم على المشرب ومنه قولهم الصيف
ضيعت اللبن والشتوي قائم على الماكل
وعناصره ثلاثه التمر والسمن والبر ففي
موسم سهيل يصير عندنا وفره بالتمر لا ده
خلص سهيل تلمست التمر بالليل وفي موسم
الحميمين يصير عندنا وفره بالبر لا تامن
القرض دام البر
والقر هي شده البروده وفي موسم العقارب
يصير عندنا وفره بسمن ولذلك سموا عقرب
الدسم لان سامي يصير من تشرين عندنا واهل
الشمال والجنوب والشرق والغرب
تتوام وتتناسب مع الثقافه يا وليدي ترى
مريت ما ض عليك باللي اكله دويف وناره
وليف ولا تقرب اللي اكله تمر وناره
سمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]